so with this tour that you're talking
about I was sad too
I didn't I never heard of this disease
that you you have I called it IBS
irritable bowel and Robin was shocked it
was like really this Fran thing can't
take a [ __ ] before he goes I be an
incomplete but but all jokes aside
getting older just sucks it does and I
thought that's what it was you know when
I first felt some weakness in my legs
and like what happened you were like
Walker how many years ago did you start
to feel these symptoms eight or nine
years ago and you'd be walking around
and say oh my legs don't feel right yeah
I would like walking up a slight incline
or walking up stairs don't walking down
stairs is the most difficult was the
most is still the most difficult thing
to do because you're in great shape you
know it's not like you're not a guy who
didn't take care of himself
no I woke out like crazy because the
only thing there's no drug yet we're
doing a drug trial in starting in May
thank goodness but the the only thing is
with this disease I just didn't know how
how quickly it was going to progress and
it's called IBM yeah inclusion body
myositis and it's not something a lot of
people have so therefore 24,000 people
are known to have it but I believe
there's a lot more that don't know they
have it they just think like I did I'm
getting alright it's starting to affect
your hands is what I read so when you
play guitar is it noticeable or at this
point you're all okay no it's not
noticeable to anybody but me at the
moment
right I test it with my band because
they know they know me inside out am i
playing obviously so but no it's not but
but as I've said before recently it's in
a year's time I don't think it's going
to be that's why we're doing the
farewell tour now the doctor said to you
in a year's time you might not be able
to play guitar no I'm just feel it yeah
so that's why I'm recording as much
ivory we're working on our fourth album
right now since October hmm because I
just want to record as much as possible
in the show
to space of time for obvious reasons and
you're probably only more in love with
the guitar now because you are playing
so much and the band the band is like
killing it it's just unbelievable how
great this stuff is well it's very it's
full of passion for obvious reasons as
well so when's the tour start June and
you're the promising us this is not like
the who know you are you are not gonna
have we're not gonna see that this is
your last tour but then it's several
weeks later it'll be another new tour no
no this is it what was the Peter
Frampton last tour
you know this drug trial there's been no
traditional drug yet that's worked with
with IBM so obviously I'm getting
involved in trying to find something and
if it were to work and if it were to
arrest where I'm at right now
then there might be a miracle to it you
know but with the miracle tour I like
the random about that